Ticketmaster is now accused of running
what looks like an underground ticket
scalping project that may be driving up
prices and costing consumers Millions
an investigation by the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation and the Toronto
Star claims the box office giant is
helping scalpers buy tickets and resell
them with a secret program vladimir
duthiers of our streaming network cbsn
is here with more from one of the
reporters who went undercover in the
investigation lab good morning good
morning there's no federal law against
ticket scalping but Ticketmaster has
publicly opposed the practice in the
past privately though it may be turning
a blind eye to it and making a profit
wearing hidden cameras journalists from
the Toronto Star and CBC pose as
scalpers at a major live entertainment
conference in Las Vegas in July that's
where they found Ticketmaster
representatives appearing to pitch a
company owned resale platform used by
ticket scalpers
just a few sets of tickets frankly just
had the gumption to try they become a
pretty good partner for
they have the secret scalper program
that they don't talk about in any
corporate reports CBC investigative
reporter Dave seg lens is one of the
reporters who went undercover posing as
a ticket broker from Toronto what we
discovered is they are selling something
called trade desk which is an online
system is it's purposely designed for
professional scalpers it helps manage
large inventories here's how it works
scalpers set up fake accounts to buy
tickets in bulk on Ticketmaster dot-com
since the website limits how many
tickets one person can buy the scalpers
then sell those tickets at inflated
prices on trade desk I want to know this
very good on whether Ticketmaster is
going to be policing us using our
multiple accounts
[Music]
ticketmaster can then make money off
fees from the initial ticket sale and
the resold scalped ticket for example
cbc analyzed ticket sales for a Bruno
Mars concert and calculated that
Ticketmaster could make up to six
hundred and fifty eight thousand dollars
in fees half of that coming from scalped
tickets I'm hoping from an investigation
like this we're really bringing
transparency so that people can look at
this and ask whether this is right moral
ethical legal in a statement to the
Toronto Star and CBC Ticketmaster says
in part that it offers a safe and fair
place for fans to shop buy and sell
tickets and that it operates that
marketplace more transparently and
securely than any other Ticketmaster and
its parent company Live Nation have not
returned our own requests for comment
Nora
alright glad thank you I've never bought
a ticket from a scalper no listen ticket
prices are there's a lot of people are a
lot upset a lot of people are upset
about ticket prices already this is not
going to help yeah you know it's just
it's so hard to get tickets as it is to
concerts in demand different prices yeah
and and the trust who you're buying from
right